programming talks Oz is going to start
us off by telling us that CNF is a Bad
Thing particularly
dig out of at all yes so yeah thank you
very much for inviting me I've been
enjoying the talks so far
has been great uh I will talk about
something slightly different even for
sort of CSP people this is higher level
in terms of abstraction
and yes one of the harder problems I
have to answer is what's your name and I
I've been sort of called Oz uh
throughout the years that's okay you can
call me also as long as you don't joke
about doctors okay so I'll talk about
abstract modeling and I've wanted to put
the name of this tool in the title
conjure which is the main sort of
software tool that we have and that's uh
include that contains a lot of the
implementation of these ideas and I'll
talk about some of the high level sort
of motivation why we are even doing this
and I'll give some examples of some of
the things that are enabled if you start
from a higher level proper
representation that's what I want to do
and and one more one warning as I Was
preparing this I learned about this
PowerPoint animation so I'll use that
okay so to tie
my background a little bit to to the
event I've been taking some notes and I
included some of them in these slides so
this is like not some of them are not
direct quotations but things people
brought up here and generally uh sort of
I selected a few a few of the comments a
few of the remarks people made that
would help make my arguments really
so one of them was from first slide is
from today fantastic talk from John
hooker I think I've seen a few versions
of this talk before but this one was
sort of getting uh very clear to the to
the final message which I which I
thought was all of these approaches
being isomorphic to each other and how
they've been developing independently
but sort of with cross fertilization
between approaches and I think someone
who was sitting at the front here asked
the main question I wanted to ask which
is if that is so why does one approach
work much better than other approach in
practice for a given problem
I guess this is the million dollar
question but sort of some of the some of
the things I'll say today are are about
how to handle this how to use this maybe
as a as a blessing rather than a curse
and and choose some of these options uh
in a slightly better way so Thorson's
told I I picked one of the examples when
he was talking about this Ubuntu package
manager and how experts developed and
models and they weren't sure which one
to use so even if you if you take
Experts of these systems and put you put
you give them enough time they will
develop some of these models they will
develop different encodings but they
won't be sure before they experiment
computationally about which one uh which
one will be will be the best one for for
the Practical applications they are
trying to solve so Kieran mentioned the
Fairly large gap between what the user
writes in constraint satisfaction
problem solving generally and what the
solver gets this is part of the culture
I guess in constraint programming where
we don't really trust the user very much
we sort of ask the user to do as little
as they can before they sort of specify
the problem fully and then stop we want
to do we want to take care of the rest
uh because sort of if you let users tell
you what they want how they want the
solver to work we have examples of even
expert users giving you wrong advice I
think mate was making a similar point in
several occasions about this not
trusting the user and or even automated
tuners which I have some conflicting
opinions about that but not trusting the
user I'm almost almost there with them
okay some more yesterday's uh very
exciting session where Karen was asking
are you are you a proof Theory person or
geek who develop solvers I'm a geek I
don't develop a lot of solvers so I
develop more modeling tools so sort of
higher level things uh and another
example I thought this was interesting
because it's not necessarily in the area
of community optimization or sat solving
uh from Tom Cruise about writing to a
book on 25 sort of sorting algorithms
but not knowing which one to use when
presented to the real sorting task this
this happens to us all the time only the
difference may be
is is sort of bigger so the difference
between the best option and the worst
option can be orders of magnitude figure
in in when you're solving MP problems
and yes this is the last one in in the
roadmap talk Kareem said something like
you know we are giving these a CNF
formulas and we are trying to solve we
are trying to uh we we better try to
understand rather than trying to find
the thing that will go the fastest and
one of the things you came to as a
conclusion is can we recover the high
level structure from from the CNF and my
point is well we better not destroy it
in the first place okay so we better
capture the problem capture the problem
specification at a level where the
structure is clear and then we convert
it down to uh other data structures that
enable maybe efficient solving and we
could do that conversion in multiple
ways and we could also uh
we can either we can be efficient in our
conversion and we can choose how to
convert it for different settings okay
so yes a lot more practical than most of
the books so far mostly about what
happens before we solve my goal today is
to convince you that there's value in
capturing the problem without losing the
high level structure the problem already
has okay so if you capture the problem
there in something that is eventually
going to be executable and then you do
some automated translation to a lower
level solver there is value other than
just making your life easier in in this
in this game so yes this is a bit of
advertisement if you want to learn more
about these tools and sort of associated
papers as well
yes so I can only fit so much in 45
minutes this is a whole body of work
this is a whole sort of area of work uh
this is going to be a high level tour of
the kind of things we work on
so not a deep type on any individual
thing however I want to give you uh a
flavor of the kind of work we do and I
will be very happy to talk more if
you're interested interested okay
so we have in one or one occasion or
another we have talked about these sort
of different Technologies okay I I don't
know what to call them really I don't
know what to call the fields either
there's been a recent good blog post
about what sort of how to how to name
this field I think that's that's quite
an interesting area an interesting
discussion to be had but from my angle I
start from constraint programming so
from my lens this is constraint
programming and similar to uh a field of
similar similar methods so building
satiability is one smt and Kieran uh
made this point about how SMP solvers
and CPU solvers are seem to be
converging I agree with that MIP or
integer programming or linear
programming mathematical programming in
general answer set programming and also
local search methods these are all sort
of related fields right here's an
observation none of these approaches
dominate right there are classes of
problems where one method is better so
if we say scheduling you are immediately
thinking of one one or another approach
approach if I say something about
numerical optimization you're thinking
about another approach so there are
classes of problems where one method is
clearly better than than another method
and maybe more interestingly even within
a class depending on the data you don't
necessarily know which method will be
faster okay so maybe within a class
certain kind of scheduling problem
there might be a data dependent reason
for why MIP will be better for some
instances and that will be better better
for other instances
okay so this is a sort of almost a
hierarchy of the different levels of
abstraction we have so sad we have
Boolean decision variables moving
constraints with mathematical
programming we now have numeric decision
variables and essentially a system of
inequalities to represent the
constraints in CP and smt typically the
decision variables stay as integer
domains but we get we get a richer set
of constraints okay so we don't really
gain a lot in terms of abstraction in
the domain of of decision variables but
we gain a lot of abstraction in these
sets of constraints we have when you go
to this abstract problem specification
languages the one I will describe today
is Essence the additional thing we are
getting the Delta is a richer set of
domains so we are now starting from a a
language where we say I'm trying to find
the partition or I'm trying to find an
injective function okay so that's the
kind of domain structure that I'm
starting with
so in practice if you are when you are
trying to solve a problem what is
significant what what gives you the sort
of speed up or the performance
Improvement between multiple options so
the methodology you you use it could be
sort of CP sat or a map or whatever
which sober you use specifically the
soul Bridge selection the solar settings
so most of the time people play this
game right the tuning is at Silver to to
make it go faster for a given set of
problem instances
and which model you use so the encoding
that you use to to get uh before you
start solving such I actually had a
terminology slide before this which I
removed because Kieran gave the
terminology that I'm using as well so I
start with problems and models and
instances of those models and the
solution is what comes out
so the core idea here is start capture
the problem at a high level
dispose all of these options and then
let's other systems make the decision
decisions okay so choose later
decoupling the compilation so converting
the problem statements to a low level
solvable thing from actually choosing
which option to go for
uh
out of these options
I claim most of the time in practice
what matters most is the model
okay so it's not just my claim I took a
photo here this photo is from
2013 so that's the phone I had at the
time and I was sitting at the back so
it's not very good I don't expect you to
be able to read this this is the
readable version this is
ACP the CP conference research
excellence awards uh
talk and on the slide he has this he
says when solving a problem using
constraint programming you have a
potential for gaining performance
improving performance tenfold thousand
fold a billion fold there might be an
exaggeration here
however corresponding to those different
kinds of things you can do so playing
with your data structures changing the
search strategy or the model itself
the chance of success sort of goes down
drastically so if you play with your
data structures if you started with a
naive data structure and you improve
your data structures 95 chance he
reckons you will gain a 10 volt increase
in in performance if you play with your
search strategies you have to be sort of
one percent of the time but you will
actually gain a sort of thousand fold
increase
in very rare occasions where you find
the better encoding a better model of
your problem you will actually improve
the performance greatly however this
doesn't happen very often okay so
modeling tends to be quite significant
there are different kinds of modeling
decisions multiple ways to model a
single given problem and this has a huge
impact on on solving performance in CP
this is sort of folk wisdom that people
say modeling is an art it's not a
science right but we can we make it a
science how would you make it a science
and just to recap I think this has been
said again uh before maybe Yesterday by
someone the whole the general sort of
Holy Grail of computer science is user
States the problem computers solves the
problem right so can we change it in a
way that the statement of the problem is
what is the only thing we need from the
user and the model including the model
helps encode it to a low level is done
by the computer
okay
so I've done a very broad categorization
of the kinds of modeling decisions we
have to make okay so I realize I've I'm
into this talk so maybe
15 minutes into the talk and I haven't
given you an example of this input
language and I'll I will give you one
soon
but before that I'll I want to say
a few more things about what kinds of
decisions I'm talking about so modeling
decisions the first one and this is
mainly based on Barbara Smith's chapter
from from the handbook of constraint
programming which is a great chapter
the main thing you want to decide is
choosing your Viewpoint this is how you
choose to encode your decisions okay
once you do that depending on that you
choose how you will formulate each
constraint and there will be several
ways of formulating each constraint even
when you fix the Viewpoint related to
this
there are tricks which involve adding
multiple viewpoints and channeling
constraints between these viewpoints I
guess in the set encoding sense it would
be a direct encoding and an order
encoding with channeling concerns
between them and opportunities for
symmetry breaking because we are
deciding how the Viewpoint is
constructed so we are able to break
symmetry at that time
one more observation this sort of thing
happens in other fields so compilers
general for general purpose programming
languages they are similar there isn't a
single way of compiling a high level
program even if if you are starting from
C to a low level outputs
what do compilers do mostly in practice
what they do is they use heuristics okay
so they run their compiler on a bunch of
different sort of typical programs they
want to they want to be compiling and
they fine-tune their heuristics and they
typically use these this is not always
what they do sometimes when you are
compiling for production for a specific
given sort of Hardware architecture you
can spend more time and fine-tune your
heuristics for that specific application
so they do that sort of thing as well in
general purpose programming one key
difference here is the difference here
can be much larger than General grips
programming right
okay
this is now uh sort of the software
architecture of the toolkit I'll be
talking about
conjure sits at the top here and it
takes a problem specification the
problem specification is a parameterized
description of your problem okay and it
also later on can take parameters to
instantiate this problem so crucially
one thing that conjured does is it
converts the specification to a lower
level language at the level of salbero
which is another tool that we have
uh ethic problem class level so this
conversion here happens independently of
the data which means you'll be able to
convert a high level problem
specification to a low level thing that
is still parameterized hence you are
then able to spend as much time
essentially as much time as you want in
this in this in this part because
anything you spent anytime you spend
will be amortized over all the instances
you want to solve
uh the languages here on this on this
diagram are Essence here and Essence
Prime Essence has the features uh the
additional features like abstract
domains sets and functions and relations
I'll give you a full list in a minute
this middle language here
has more widely supported data types in
terms of domains so it basically has
integers and billions okay so from here
on we are able to Target a specific
solver okay so Essence Prime is solver
independent
and it does solver dependence over
targets its compilation from there
uh there are a bunch of backends that we
support So minion is Ace over that is
developed in San Andreas in addition to
minion minion is is quite a good
function solver but it it is maybe
outdated now it doesn't have closed
learning for example uh we support other
solvers so we support G-Code and chuffed
we support a bunch of sat solvers these
are just some of the names cassette and
category included of course we support a
bunch of smt solvers we can produce
input for C Plex we can produce uh
neighborhoods that will work for a local
search solver and you might have heard
of this language called flatzing which
is which is developed by another group
but it allows us access to another sort
of set of solvers as well
okay I did spend quite a lot of time
before showing you an actual example
here's the example
has to do with golfers
you may have heard of the social golfers
problem
the coordinator of a local golf club has
come to you with the following problem
in the club there are 32 social golfers
each of whom play golf once a week and
always in groups of four they would like
you to come up with a schedule for play
of play of these golfers so it lost as
many weeks as possible a variant of this
problem is is the maximal socialization
variant which is given here the the
problem is generalized to scheduling G
groups of s golfers
over W Weeks such that no golf replays
in the same group as any other golfer
twice so maximum socialization is
achieved okay so this is the problem
statement we are starting with and if
you haven't heard of CSP before it's
quite a good resource esp.org this is
problem number 10 described on CSP lib
with more details and links to to papers
uh not solve this problem
so keeping that problem in mind I will
show you the essence problem
specification of this problem so this is
a recap that's the problem we are trying
to Define here we say we are given three
integers okay these will have to be one
or greater
we need to
we Define a type called goldfish this is
one of the key features of of this
language and this is to do with symmetry
breaking so we say golfers is a type of
this size G times s many so I have that
many golfers but when defined like this
the individual growth risk cannot be
identified so a core sort of property of
the sourceful governance problem is that
you don't you don't you don't have to
identify the golfers if you find the
solution
uh any solution you can take you can
swap the names of the golfers around and
you'll get to a symmetric solution so we
we just say that the task is to find the
schedule which is a set size W so W
Weeks each week meaning the partition
which is G parts and each part is s
sizes so that's one decision variable in
this terminology okay of course that's
not going to end up being a single
decision variable independent of which
solver you use we have to compile it
down to a bunch of decision variables
eventually
so there is a single domain a a single
decision variable and a single
constraint the constraint here is for
any given two golfers that aren't
identical so I'm not identifying the
golfer this is a universal
quantification of over all pairs of
golfers
the only thing I'm saying is they don't
they can't be the same uh if I sum over
this week
if I have a sum configuration over the
schedule which gives me a week week is a
partition so on in this partition G1 and
G2 can't be together more than once
okay
so
it is quite Compact and it requires you
to learn this language and understand
this language and the syntax of the
language however the building blocks
that we've used are building blocks
hopefully more people are familiar with
so these are building blocks from sort
of discrete maths right you have sets
you have partitions and you have a host
of operators you can use on these that
will allow you to State the problem at
this level of abstraction so what do we
do then we use the tool to convert this
to a
well potentially a number of essence
Prime models and then use cellular to go
down to one of our backend tools
okay so I I have
a bit more about the language now
so a problem specification language
Essence this is made up of a number of
top level statements and each top level
statement will be one of these it is
either a declaration so declaring a
decision variable or a parameter a
constraint an objective statement
conditions on valid instances so you
could say I only support instances where
these conditions hold and their search
directors so I'm not going to say very
much about them
we generally at this level of
abstraction we omit the search
directives and leave it to the defaults
most of the time
okay so the Declarations look like this
you say uh if you're if you're trying to
find it if you are defining a decision
variable you say fine the next such that
it has this domain the parameters are
defined in a similar way we have Syntax
for defining aliases
the constraints are defined using a such
that keyword objective is defined using
minimizing or maximizing and the
conditions are similarly to constraints
but instead of such that we say where
okay here's another example now
this is the round robin tournament
scheduling problem again I think this is
on CSP the best value yes problem 26. so
this one uses similar features to what
we had before we are given a single
integer and we have a where statement
this time so this problem is defined
only when the number of teams is even
yeah
explain what that syntax is the one dot
dot
is it this one yeah it is it is range
syntax so it says this this integer can
take value from one and above
this is a problem parameter it's not a
decision variable so the parameter can
be any positive number in this case
where some problem classes Define an
infinite number of instances so you
allow unbounded
okay so as long as that's integers is an
even integer
then we Define a bunch of data types
again here so the decision variable we
are using this time is we are using a
relation variable and it is a relation
of three things so weeks periods and the
set so these can be nested as well we
have the the more abstract decision
variable types these domains like
relation and set and they can be nested
so I can have a relation between
essentially an integer another integer
and the set of pairs well I say
essentially an integer because these are
what we call unnamed types so they are
symmetric they can be swapped around
okay another example I just want to show
a few examples so you get the feeling of
of the language
this is another one the covering array
problem at least the version that we
have on CSP lift this isn't done problem
number 45. uh it has four integer
variables in this case G has to be at
least two and a
um
fairly complex condition on what these
values have to be okay so they have to
satisfy these properties for it to be a
valid instance and you define again your
types here and in this case the thing we
are trying to find is a multi-set of
size B of A total function so a total
function is going to be a mapping
between these switches to the alphabet
one interesting feature I think is that
this Universal quantification here in
the constraints definition is a for all
on a function domain as well so this one
says any function I can I can consider
and it doesn't even have to be a total
function including partial functions
which as long as they satisfy this
domain so all members of this function
domain I will post the condition so one
thing that's interesting in essence is
you could write tiny tiny uh constraints
which unroll to millions and millions of
constraints in the in the low level
okay
so here's a full list now eventually
sorry of
of the domains that we have
so we have Boolean domains integer
domains and Matrix domains matrices are
basically a multi-dimensional arrays
with a bunch of specific operators
defined on them unnamed types which is
what I showed you for symmetry breaking
enumerated types they are compiled to
integers but they they give you more
type safety
a few more convenience types tuples and
records and variants variants are tagged
unions
set multi-set sequence function relation
and partition variables so you can use
these and arbitrary nestings of these
things to Define your decision up to the
object you are trying to find
and we also have been working on adding
graphs to conjure this is also joint
work with Kieran but this is this is
still a work in progress so it exists we
have solved some problems with it but
it's not landed in the main line yet
on these different domains we have a
relatively
to this set of of attributes so you can
take a variable that has a domain a sets
domain and you can post these
constraints on it uh so at the time of
definition So when you say find me a set
you can post cardinality constraints on
it such that the maximum size of this
set will be that and minimum size will
be this for multi-set so you can say
things about number of occurrence of a
particular particular values uh so
sequences these are bounded length
sequences so they have to be a finite
length
uh functions these may be partial they
take two other domains inside there's is
arguments so it would be a function from
a set to a partition or something like
that and they take these cardinality
attributes how many entries you will
have in the function as well as
injectivity surge activity and Magic
activity attributes relations uh can be
on an arbitrary number of number of
domain elements uh and they they allow
quite uh sort of complex things to be
written using relations by using things
like relation projection for example so
like like a database you could write
relation projection operators on these
and partitions are to do with the sets
that you're partitioning okay so that
that is the full list of domains that we
support
I'll skip a few slides and I want
hopefully I've given you a flavor of the
kind of things you can expect from this
language
uh so now we have what I claim to be a
higher level language which which
doesn't require the modeler to encode
their problem in great detail so they
they only tell us the kind of
combinatorial object they are searching
for and a bunch of constraints in terms
of that combinatorial object so the rest
of the compilation will be done by this
this software too so what's what's
possible then when you start with a
language like this what sort of things
are possible so this is a bunch of
selected highlights and I'll go through
them and I'll I'll try to give you an
idea of what we've done in each in each
case uh but I should say this there is
at least one paperback in each each sort
of colored item here I have on this list
so if you want to learn more about it
please do have a look and let me know if
you're if you're interested
first one to highlight and I think this
is one of the success stories of
starting with with a high level language
like this is automated symmetry breaking
so when you start with a language like
like Essence if you write when you write
a problem specification of let's say the
social welfare's problem the essence
file that you write
talks about sets talks about functions
and talks about an unnamed collection of
objects okay so as written that doesn't
have any symmetry
what we do as modulers or encoders when
we convert that to input suitable for a
solver is we introduce the Symmetry
right when we give names to the solver
golfers or when we Define somehow
represent that set or somehow represent
the function we introduce the symmetry
what conjure does is it introduces
absolutely no symmetry okay so in in
some cases we have Flags to let it
introduce symmetry because if you are
using a local search solver you might
want some symmetry in your problem
but it has options to break absolutely
all the Symmetry that it introduces so
if there isn't asymmetry in the problem
specification there won't be a symmetry
in the encode satin coding you get in
the output okay all of the Symmetry that
is introduced is broken so a couple of
paper titles here this is very good when
you're enumerating combinatorial objects
so one of the previous talks was about
enumerating combinatorial objects and
symmetry was it was a core part I'm not
suggesting conjure out of the box we'll
we'll do you know will be as fast as as
the method that was presented there
yesterday I think it was however we have
worked with with mathematicians who will
come to us and say I'm looking for a
combinatorial object like this and I
want to count exactly the number of
times up to isomorphism that the subject
occurs and it's really useful in those
cases
second one is is streamlining
constraints you might have heard of
implied constraints before so an implied
constraint is you take a model and you
you generate constraints that are
implied by the primary constraints and
these the hope is these new general
constraints you generate the implied
ones will help you in propagation so
they will they will contain some
information that helps helps the search
so streamlining constraints can be seen
as a sort of more Reckless form of that
you are trying to come up with new
constraints but they don't have even
have to be inferred by the original
model so you are losing Solutions but
the goal is we want to generate some
implied con some streamlining
constraints which will yes lose
Solutions but they won't lose all the
solutions okay so in examples where you
are trying to find at least one solution
you can use this method to get to the
first solution more quickly
are you talking here about decision
problems or optimization problems so
mainly decision problems but we have
applied it on optimization problems okay
can you explain further on how you're
doing for optimization problems
so what one way of doing it would be
getting lower bounds right so we we
formulate the optimization problem as a
multi-objective problem and we try to
find a streamlining constraint that will
give you a good lower bound very quickly
quickly that's the kind of thing we've
done so far but they are mainly applied
on satisfaction problems okay thank you
okay so they're extremely useful when
they work they work really really well
they cut down search to like less than
one percent of the original search the
thing we are uh
the reason okay people have applied
streamlining constraints to sort of
problems without Essence right manually
like you take your problem you write the
CNF sort of generator for it and then
you go maybe some of my Solutions will
have this property then you generate an
additional constraint and see if it
works this is also called restrictions
in some in some uh sort of terminology
as the opposite of a relaxation
uh the reason it works well here is
because we are starting from a high
level language so we know they are
looking for a set or a partition or a
function we can guess streamlining
constraints we automatically generate
candidate streamlining constraints using
the high level structure so we say if
you are looking for a partition maybe
the size of your parts in the partition
will be close to regular right so the
streamlining constraints the candidates
that we generate are to do with the high
level structure and then we do the
classic uh sort of give me a set of
Representative instances you want to
solve train on some of those and test on
the rest to see if this helps
yeah this was recently published in aij
so it's it works really well when it
does
foreign
area where having access to the high
level structure is a good thing is local
search similar to large neighborhood
search but the neighborhoods are Guided
by the structure of the problem so this
we call this SNS structured guided local
search I think in that in that paper so
we use the high level problem
description to generate a description of
how the local moves will work again I
will use the same sort of partition
example if you know the user is looking
for a partition a local move could be to
take one item from one part and put it
to the next part describing that at a
low level sort of CNF formalism is very
difficult but at the high level when you
have something like essence you you know
exactly the kind of combinatorial object
they are looking for so you are able to
say okay I will move this partition in
this way as a local move so again this
is directed by the domains
and yeah we have implemented this by
using generated constraints at a high
level as a proof of concept and then
converted them to an existing solver so
it worked with any back end uh it cut
down in search so if a number of steps
you need uh drastically but it was very
slow and then we implemented a sort of
native solver that takes Essence and
then solves it at that level and that
goes much faster this is a local search
solver so it has it comes with all the
guarantee all the sort of uh properties
of a local search solver so it's
incomplete but again it works really
really well when it does when it has
high level structure to exploit
okay
next point is is channeled models so
this is a technique that is used very
commonly in CP you will find a lot of
mod ref papers modref is the modeling
and reformulation workshop in constraint
programming and a lot of CP conference
papers as well where people take a a
model and they take another model of the
same problem and then they realize
constraint a is written and sort of
propagated really well in this model and
constraint p is written and propagated
very well in this other model so they
will write a mishmash which has both
representations channeling constraints
and model A is represented using first
representation constraint a is
represented using first representation
and B using the second representation so
we have the ability to generate
channeled models automatically out of
these these systems so you have a set
variable at the Top If you have multiple
ways of converting it to the low level
you can in the same model convert it to
one representation and the other one as
well adds automated channeling
constraints and then you will have a
problem which has both represent the
model which has both representations in
it
so there's been a few papers where we
show how this works it can help with
propagation
it can also help with search so you
could have a problem completely defined
in terms of one representation but you
keep around another representation just
for search because it's better if you
just backtrack over this other object
okay
almost as a direct sort of consequence
of what I said before if you have
multiple ways of representing each high
level decision variable you can also
generate multiple models right you don't
have to generate just one model in some
cases because of a combinatory explosion
really you can get thousands and
thousands of models out of conjure right
so you give it different options you say
for this set use this source of
representation for this function use
that sort of representation and you can
get one model and another model and we
have shown that starting from a single
high level Essence file you can generate
three separate models which were
previously published handwritten by
experts okay so people sitting down and
writing sober independent models using a
language like Essence prime or minnesink
and we are able to generate these three
separate models automatically out of a
single high level description
this enables a bunch of things so one of
them is algorithm tuning or algorithm
selection right you could choose which
model to use give depending on data you
can Implement heuristics just like how
what I was saying about compilers you
could have some built-in heuristics that
you fiddle with over time and we have
one called Compact and it seems to work
really well so that's our default
heuristic for getting a compact
representation in the output as the name
suggests
okay
a few more things left and then I'll
wrap up
next one is to do with the tool that we
have in the middle the second tool in
the tool chain soluble row and this tool
is is instance level so it does the
instantiation right it is the First Tool
in the tool chain that has access to the
data and its main goal is to convert
Essence Prime to inputs suitable for a
particular solver so it's targeting your
solver as well
uh there are two
optimizations done inside of cyber I
would like to highlight first one is
common sub expression elimination
it was it was covered in a few a few
talks that constraint programming
solvers mostly consumed programmers
always they work by processing
constraints one at a time right so
communication between constraints is can
be a bottleneck so common sub expression
elimination inside of a model can be a
way of connecting constraints so if you
have constraints a which is a complex
expression in it constraint B which has
the similar or the same complex
expression in it if you take extract out
an auxiliary decision variable which
represents this value and uh use that in
both of the places you can connect the
two constraints and this can help
reasoning
significantly so this is applied
automatically depending on sort of
different flags you set in the tool
another one is automatic tabulation so
constrained solvers from sort of the old
ages always
um supported explicit representations of
constraints so you were always able to
say here's a table of allowed
assignments for my n variables choose
one like two
assign values such that the values come
from a row of the stable so that's
generally seen as a bad thing because
you don't want to explicitly list all
the all the options if you can
symbolically write down an expression
however it really helps in some cases uh
partly because table constraints so
these are called table constraints in
the solvers generally can achieve GAC
even if your original formulation
couldn't
so selectively we can tabulate
constraints and we could tabulate
conjunctions of constraints as well so
if you have two constraints which maybe
together do not achieve GAC you could
put them together and tabulate them also
in a limited scope as well so maybe not
in the entire scope of the original
constraint and you will achieve GAC
uh
next one
so now that we have these options okay
options for generating alternative
models and options for using alternative
solvers for a given single problem
specification we I sort of like we have
in several papers shown how sort of
selecting a model and selecting a solver
is a good idea for regular data set so
one step after this is now I have a
problem I don't necessarily have data
for this problem yet right I've defined
the problem the social Gophers problem
or something which has more data maybe a
flight Crew Scheduling problem
and I want to solve this in practice
I don't know which solver which model I
should go for so we've developed a
system which takes advantage of this
sort of exposing of the options where we
can say find me all the instances where
cplex is slower than
catego right so you run it for a few
days and it goes and says okay here are
the kinds of instances you might want to
look at if you want to find instances
where MIP is faster or the other way
around
so this is sort of interesting because
oftentimes when we are doing science we
want to be given a set of instances and
we don't want to be cherry picking right
we don't want to be saying oh this kind
of instance works out here so I'll focus
on them this is sort of the other way
around the flip side of that approach
where we are actually automating the
cherry picking process what we can do
then is we can identify problems or
instances where a certain method is
slower maybe that method is overall
faster than the other one but certain
method is slower in this corner of the
instant space and then you can focus on
this sort of kind of instances and maybe
improve your solver for that sort of
instance
okay
so I've said a lot the main thing I
wanted to say was
there are opportunities of things to do
to improve your model improve the kind
of solver selection you can you can make
if you start from a high level problem
specification okay that is as free as
possible of modeling decisions
so don't let the user destroy the
structure that's in the problem but
capture it there and automate the rest
so this this will allow efficient
translation to multiple models and
solvers once we expose the options and
choose depending on the data uh this is
of course
also like parts of this talk I maybe
made it sound like it is sort of the
Silver Bullet cyber bullet it isn't
there are cases where we you know we
know there's a better representation
that conjure doesn't generate so we have
to do more programming to capture that
uh better choosing so we know there are
good options that are automated choosing
systems do not do not go for
a good thing we are trying to work on is
a better understanding of when it works
and explaining why it works in those
cases
um and using this sort of
oh analysis of finding where it works
and where it doesn't so we can better
better understand the underlying sort of
difficulty why certain things are
difficult wise other things aren't okay
uh so that's that's all I wanted to say
here are some links if you want to learn
more and if you want to talk to me I'll
be around this week uh and yeah I'll be
happy to answer any questions people
might have
so if you want to start a new solver to
the the this current tool chain how much
work would you say it would be to get
double rotor generate things for your
new silver
well it depends uh people might be
familiar with minizync mini zinc has
better support for extensibility to be
honest because they have a language in
which you can the solver developer can
write a mapping for us you would have to
write some Java code
that you you basically need to write a
single class uh which will tell you how
to translate and depending on how
different your solar is to an existing
solver that could be difficult or not so
when we added smt so we had four
different theories as separate back ends
we took the satin coding back end as a
basis because the one of the beat users
of smt is you can always fall back to
SATs so that wasn't very difficult in
that sense but before we added enough
sort of smt specific translations it
wasn't very good and it started being
good so yes it requires some work
so um the pros and cons of CNF I guess
is uh it's it's a very low level
representation but then when you're
doing stat solving like given that I
accept that my CNF formula is my problem
uh I sort of get in also we are drat or
whatever I get an iron cap proof that
now I have solved this problem correctly
uh going to a much higher level and
generating all these different
representations and maybe channeling
constraints sort of raises the issue of
of course you guys would never introduce
bugs in your code that's not what I'm
trying to suggest but you know all of
these different representations how do I
know that they're even the same are they
the equivalent can I prove this in some
way like have you thought about proof
vlogging in your context for conjure and
what that would mean great question I've
been getting this question since my PhD
and I've done some work on this uh and
like there's a possibility of actually
proving each translation right because
it is you can structure it in a way
where it is it is like a rewriting
system so you start with a high level
language and you make it's a single
modification at each step and as long as
you approve this sort of small step
semantics you might you might have hope
to prove the entire thing correct uh
however it is difficult because it is
you know it's quite a big system so what
I would do if I wanted provable
correctness I guess is for I guess unsat
uh instances you you could use the same
tool chain to do it in a few different
ways right you could have one
representation or one sort of path from
the top to the bottom which you prove
fully or I try to understand the simple
one maybe that doesn't give you the
fastest the best CNF but that is when
you what you use to get the rid a faster
one in a portfolio so you maybe you run
the one that you don't trust that much
and it gives you gives you a solution
and then you run the slower one if and
you need a proof kind of thing but yeah
I think that's in terms of research I
think that's a very exciting thing to do
but I think it's going to be difficult
to prove the entire rewriting system
correct
it's not proven correct and we had
spokes I was
I was just gonna ask um do you think
you're you so I'm coming from a CP
background
um and pretty used to dealing with tools
like many zinc Etc do you think you're
modeling abstractions actually require
your users to be stronger mathematically
yeah it might might I mean
ease of use isn't a primary goal right
it happens to also I think in general
make it easier to use because more
people are familiar with discrete maths
than they are with I don't know the
cumulative constraints
but that wasn't an explicit goal from
the start we never claimed like writing
something in essence will be easier like
you you end up writing 10 lines but each
line might take more effort than writing
100 lines of minozing maybe so I
appreciate that
how many users like you know bijective
subjective function is all this stuff
if you look at you know some of the
questions being asked on
that may be true yeah if
if it it's it if you buy that argument
that it isn't ease of use but it
actually will make it faster if you
happen to write it in this language if
you capture it in this language then you
have access to all of these other bells
and whistles then maybe that is
incentive enough for people to you know
learn this kind of abstraction maybe not
you're right A lot of people who come
from a programming background find
generating CNF by hand maybe easier or
using an smt sober maybe easier or
minutes maybe easier foreign
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
next speaker Jules will be telling us
about even more interesting things we
can do when we have